[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau d' interdit
d'interdire à la question quoi de neuf
dans la culture depuis le début du 21e
siècle il y a une réponse évidente les
séries télé produits de produits bas de
gamme au siècle dernier dont on ne
parlait jamais sans un certain dédain
elles sont devenues avec les années 2006
prestigieuses qu'elles ont supplanté le
cinéma et même la musique dont les
conversations les séries sont devenus la
référence de notre époque ce n'est donc
pas par hasard si l'on commence à les
regarder avec une certaine suspicion
trop jolie pour être honnête trop
chronophage pour être seulement
divertissante et puis elle rapporte trop
d'argent pour être gratuit tous en
conséquence les séries ne saurait-elle
pas le nouvel opium du peuple pour en
débattre nous avons invité françois
bégaudeau vous êtes écrivain vous êtes
l'auteur entre autres d'histoire de ta
bêtise et de notre joie aux éditions
fayard depuis 2010 9 d'également
critique de cinéma sur le podcast
intitulé la gêne occasionnée en
compagnie d'un même interlocuteur se
faisant appeler l'homme qui n'a pas de
prénom c'est bien le titre c'est bien ça
il y est souvent question de série enfin
vous faites partie des 90 auteurs de
nouveau monde qui est paru en août
dernier aux éditions amsterdam voulzy
signé un court texte polémique contre
les élites les séries télé que leur
reprochez vous en deux mots je pense que
telles qu'elles sont produites et telles
qu'elles sont consommés les séries
s'inscrivent dans ce qu'on appelle
l'économie de l'attention ou il s'agit
essentiellement de susciter l'attention
du consommateur mais je trouve que ce
mode attention est très très mal
configuré parce que je pense qu'au
contraire les séries telles que leurs
formes l'induit suscite au contraire une
nonne attention ou une moindre attention
donc ma question c'est de savoir mais
qu'est ce qui se passe dans la tête des
gens quand ils consomment une série et
mon intuition qui vient beaucoup de
l'observation de moi même devant les
séries ce qui se passe pas grand chose
je pense qu'en fait la forme série
interdit toute forme d'expérience
véritable et notamment déclenché et
éthiques virginie martin vous vous êtes
politiste professeure et chercheuse à la
cass business school à paris où vous
avez créé et dirigé le programme soft
power et médias avant de prendre la
responsabilité du media lab au moment
même où été publié le nouveau monde avec
le texte de françois bégaudeau fin août
vous sortiez chez humaines sciences le
charme discret des séries dans lequel
vous vous intéressiez à l'aspect
idéologique des séries est leur
influence dans le monde d'aujourd'hui je
vous avez reçus dans cette émission à
cette occasion c'est le nouvel opium du
peuple les séries pour vous
ça dépend un petit peu de son temps par
de manière quand même par rapport à
l'histoire les séries c'est quand même
très vieux et c'est pas nouveau donc
c'est peut-être un débat j'allais dire
un peu de boomer de dire attention les
séries sont dangereuses si je puis dire
dans la jeunesse c'est pas comme ça que
ça se voit mais non plus aussi dans les
universités c'est un objet je n'aime pas
ce terme en tout cas c'est un élément du
décor culturel qui est important
maintenant c'est certain que la
plateforme bien entendu joue beaucoup
aussi dans l'ampleur que prennent
aujourd'hui dans nos quotidiens les
séries ou comme vous disiez tout à
l'heure frédéric dans les conversations
bien entendu car de cornillon vous vous
enseigner la littérature comparée à
l'université de nîmes vous êtes membre
de gheest le groupe universitaire
d'études sur les séries télé vous avez
publié chez honoré champion en 2018
sérialité et transmédia lite est infinie
des fictions contemporaines c'est sur la
place de la fiction dans le monde
d'aujourd'hui alors opium ou pas opium
du peuple la série
maintenant moi je pense pas du tout que
ce soit l'opium du peuple et je pense
qu'au contraire les séries peuvent être
vraiment le lieu d'une expérience
esthétique c'est même ce qui est en fait
au coeur de mon travail depuis des
années donc j'espère que c'est sur ces
éléments qu'on va convenir tout à
l'heure mais je pense que l'élément déjà
centrale c'est de qualifier les séries
en général qu'est ce que ça veut dire
les séries parce que les séries c'est
une diversité de modes de production
c'est une diversité historique c'est une
diversité de formes et donc ça me paraît
difficile de porter un jugement sur les
séries en général alors les séries
voyait une uniformité a priori françois
bégaudeau n'en était finalement bien sûr
qu'une une telle intel c'est culturel
admet un foisonnement une diversité et
des disparités à l'infini savait pas de
problème mais je pense que ça peut être
ils ont presque un préalable de notre
discussion admettons quand même qu'il y
ait une relative unité parce que sinon
c'est vrai qu'on va se perdre en
exception et un bon donc je pense qu'il
ya quand même une forme standard de la
série qui s'est cristallisée peut-être
nécrosés je sais pas fin des années 90
début des années 2000 il a basculé biais
du bio en gros moi ce qui me frappe dans
un certain nombre de séries que j'ai pu
regarder plus ou moins bien des parfois
très médiocre des plus les plus
intéressantes il ya quand même comme ça
un panel il ya un spectre de qualité un
peu différent on peut dire moi ce qui me
frappe par exemple quelque chose il ya
une unité formelle qui est celle de la
scène courte c'est pas rien je ne sais
pas rien quand on vient comme moi du
cinéma j'ai grandi avec le cinéma
j'écris dessus tu parles dessus je me
suis beaucoup structurée autour du
cinéma il y avait il y avait cette idée
quand même qu'un peu le l'unité d'un
film c'était là ce n est que dans cette
scène il pouvait se passer un truc et
notamment sur lazer durée c'est une
certaine école du cinéma une certaine
filiation naturelle est vrai est ce que
vous voyez encore des films ont fait
durer la scène l'écouté aller voir
memoria d'apichatpong weerasethakul vous
avez des plans fixes de cinq six minutes
ou qui sont le lieu d'une expérience je
dis pas qu'ils feraient tomber dans ce
genre de radicalité même si je trouve le
film absolument magnifique mais ça
continue à se faire bien sûr vous voyez
nocturne au de francesco rosi qui est un
documentariste extraordinaire qui a
récemment livré ceci nous amène à
tournon vous avez des plans longs qui me
semble est comment dire le cadre
possible spatio-temporelle d'une
expérience il se passe des choses quoi
c'est vrai que ce qui me frappe dans la
forme série telle qu'elle s'est
standardisée c'est la brièveté des
scènes mais la brièveté des scènes lé pa
incidente je pense qu'elle fait partie
du programme puisqu'il s'agit toujours
de de maintenir le consommateur devant
son écran puisqu'on parle maintenant
d'écrans d'ordinateur bien sûr c'est
comme ça qu'elles sont consommés et ça
tient beaucoup sur le fait que si jamais
il s'ennuie un peu dentelle cède il ya
toujours la promesse qu'on va bientôt
passer à la scène suivante ce qui
correspond soudan souvent d'ailleurs ce
qui coïncide souvent au fait de passer
avec un personnage qui serait différent
puisque une des techniques à mon avis
qu'on retrouve dans beaucoup de séries
c'est la pluralité du système de
personnages
qu'on avait déjà d'ailleurs dans la
série non légitimes des années 80 je
veux dire dallas c'était un peu pareil
quoi si on s'emmerdait un peu avec bobby
on savait qu'une minute et après on a
r'trouvé jr si on s'emmerde avec jr on
savait qu'on ait retrouvé sous elle est
bon il ya comme ça une façon de
maintenir non pas d'attention mais la
présence j'insiste bien tu te prends
mais ce n'est pas de l'intention c'est
de la présence par comme ça un système
de brièveté des scènes voilà ça je pense
que c'est déjà quelque chose parce que
moi cette brièveté elle me met très
largement en dehors des séries et puis
surtout je pense qu'on a à faire du coup
à une forme qui est très largement
instrumental une scène ne vaut pas pour
ce qu'elles fabriquent pour ce qui s'y
passe véritablement comme intensité
intérieur à la scène mais pour ce
qu'elle raconte c'est vraiment à passer
elle fait avancer le récit 1 puisque les
séries alors ça c'est vrai aussi des
séries sondés sont hyper narrative le
récit est roi je dirais moi je pense que
pendant 100 ans dans le cinéma il ya eu
une sorte de ligne de front critique ou
intellectuelles ou esthétique entre des
gens qui étaient des partisans du
scénario d'un cinéma très scénarisé et
des gens qui pensaient qu'au contraire
le cinéma se gagner un peu contre son
scénario c'était des choses qu'on
pouvait dire aux cahiers du cinéma une
époque c'était dans les accidents
scénaristique ou de les interstices du
scénario qui avait du cinéma bon on peut
dire que la série a fait a fait
totalement gagné les premiers c'est à
dire c'est le triomphe du scénario c'est
de trion du récit je dirais que les
séries sont défaits scénaristique totaux
quoi c'est à dire qu'elles sont
pratiquement réductible à leur scénario
donc la scène et là c'est une c'est une
vocation purement instrumentale en quoi
je pense qu'on pourrait aussi faire des
analogies avec certaines formes je
dirais du capitalisme disons disons les
mots qui fâchent parce que tout y est
instrumentale tout est utile il faut
absolument qu'on fasse avancer quelque
chose et donc une scène je terminerais
là dessus pour l'instant qu'est-ce
qu'elle fait exactement par rapport à
son consommateur ou à son récepteur je
vais dire de façon plus neutre eh bien
elle lui envoie les informations il
s'agit pas de regarder quelque chose je
pense que dans une série on ne voit rien
on ne regarde pas une série c'est pas
vrai en fait c'est pas c'est pas les
yeux qui s'exerce pas raison on reçoit
des informations qui sont des
informations narrative thématique
idéologique moral mais ce sont des
informations
eh ben je veux dire je suis pas sûr que
ce soit très intéressant d'être mis en
posture de recevoir des informations ce
qui ressemble globalement à à la
position d'un spectateur de publicité en
fait la publicité envoient des
informations et son génie à la publicité
c'est la densité des informations en
voix il faut envoyer plein
d'informations en 30 secondes c'est à
peu près ce que font les scènes de série
d'accords d'ions
oui moi je ne suis pas du tout d'accord
avec ça à beaucoup de niveaux d'abord
dans un premier temps l'expérience
esthétique des séries elle vient
justement être bien du fait que c'est
une expérience alors il ya d'abord des
éléments qui font qu'ils muller à
d'autres formes artistiques et notamment
le cinéma parce qu'en fait en réalité
vous trouvez tout à fait des scènes
longues d'éléments qui sont en lien avec
la mise en scène et pas seulement des
éléments du scénario je prendrai un seul
exemple une série sur laquelle j'ai
beaucoup travaillé qui s'appelle the
left heureuse et avec cet égard on peut
clairement travailler sur la question de
du temps de de l'inscription dans une
scène et de l'expérience de là d'un
moment présent et d'autre part en fait
on voit bien dans ce discours là que il
ya deux poids deux mesures en fait c'est
à dire que on peut tout à fait tenir
exactement le même discours sur les
armes les lézardes illégitime on peut
tenir exactement le même discours sur un
cinéma qui se serait homogénéiser autour
d'éléments berciaud on peut tenir
exactement le même discours sur la
littérature on peut faire tout ça et on
lui crée pas parce que actuellement on
est dans un état où on a ou là le combat
de la légitimation il est sur la
sellette et les îles et sur le jeu vidéo
il est sur certaines choses mais ce soir
c'est un cercle en fait de légitimation
bas il faut pas confondre entre le
discours médiatique sur des objets et
les objets eux-mêmes parce que quand on
étudie effectivement ces objets quand on
y regarde on n'a pas du tout c'est la
même expérience que celle qui vient
d'être d'être évoquée en fait celle qui
vient d'être évoquée c'est le discours
médiatique actuel sur les séries et
c'est vraiment de choix sous peu à fait
différente
voilà mais pourquoi moi et pas seulement
le discours médiatique actuel c'est
aussi le discours de quelqu'un et c'est
comme ça que vous le vous le tenez
d'ailleurs françois bégaudeau qui a été
levée avec le cinéma est en fête qui se
retrouvent à regarder des séries et
c'est mon cas aussi et de se dire ça me
fait pas la même chose je voudrais quand
même préciser deux choses
il n'y a pas de combat de légitimation
c'est fini la forme légitime
actuellement c'est la série donc je ne
parle pas d'un lieu de légitimité qui
serait celui par exemple de la
littérature du cinéma d'auteur ou que
sais-je et je parlerai un art qu'il est
en train d'advenir et dont la légitimité
n'est pas advenu le nombre de travaux
universitaires vous en est d'ailleurs un
exemple qui ce qui aux quilles ont
foisonné mais dès les années 2000 autour
de la forme série est tout à fait
stupéfiant et donc la légitimité de la
série est absolument avéré je pense que
c'est plutôt maintenant les arts
considérez comme légitimes autrefois qui
sont plutôt un peu en voie de minoration
voire même de marginalisation voire
voire même de désuétude donc le combat
ne se situe pas là j'aurai aussi précisé
très rapidement après je vous laisse
parler que ce que j'ai dit tout à
l'heure sur la forme standard qui me
paraissait pouvoir être caractérisé par
la brièveté des scènes c'est quelque
chose que je n'ai pas entendu dans les
médias c'est quelque chose que j'ai
constaté envoyons des séries tout
simplement donc par exemple pour
préparer cette émission je me dis je
vais jeter un oeil à nos sur mead qui
est une série qui vient d'être venir sur
netflix on m'avait dit c'était pas mal
j'ai été comme d'habitude déçu mais je
demande donc aux spectateurs d'aller
regarder ça ce soir s'ils le peuvent ça
ce sont des moyens med comme blade m à
idées voilà et de contes et de
chronométrer la durée standard des
scènes dans cette série et peut-être de
faire le même travail sur tout un tas
d'autres séries et on s'apercevra qu'on
excède très largement la minute il ya
probablement des exceptions mais puisque
je parlais de la date du 10 ont des
régularités de cette forme je crois
qu'on peut dire qu elle se caractérise
quand même par la brièveté des scènes
berger et martin
il ya tellement de choses à dire et puis
il ya aussi des choses qui vont pas
vraiment dans dans le même sens sur fait
même chez françois bégaudeau je ne
trouve pas ce qu'il ya la question du
capitalisme dont on pourrait parler
longuement il ya la question quand même
je suis désolé de la légitimité parce
que ça sous-entend situerait humains bon
cinéma est en mauvais cinéma il ya un
cinéma aussi où les scènes sont très
rapides où ça va très vite et où on
capte de téléspectateurs le enfin le
spectateur et il faut vraiment le faire
consommer du cinéma au sens le plus
basique et capitalistique économique du
terme c'est pareil pour la littérature
il ya une littérature aussi de super
consommation aujourd'hui il assure par
exemple
des plateformes ci de littérature ou les
auteurs se publie peut même via des
amazones et et autres et autre chose
comme cela et qui finalement finissent
par être vraiment des auteurs à très
très très grand succès et là on peut
aussi parler donc il n'y a pas je veux
dire c'est trop complexe et c'est là où
je rejoins peut-être clair ou dans son
préambule quand elle disait il n'ya pas
les séries oui je pense qu'à pas les
séries néanmoins ce que je comprends ce
que dit françois mais je pense quand
même que c'est un petit peu plus
complexe que ça parce que si on prend
aussi si on va sur la brièveté pas par
exemple qui voudrait dire grosso modo
vous devez rester attentif on a une
heure d'attention papa par jour pour
amazon pour netflix pour h bio etc il
faut absolument qu'on le prenne et qu'on
le cap et c'est nous qui devons gagner
cette économie de l'attention bien sûr
qu'à cela derrière c'est évident on on
peut pas ne pas parler de cette économie
de l'attention elle est partout autour
de nous mais je pense que focaliser
cette économie de l'attention seulement
sur les séries comme si elle était le
grand coupable je trouve que c'est un
peu caricatural et ce n'est pas non plus
les maîtres en fait dans un grand tout
si on les met dans un grand tout de
l'économie de l'attention pourquoi pas
néanmoins ça n'empêche pas aussi cette
brièveté il ya des séries qui sont
beaucoup plus exigeants ce aussi que
d'autres ça je le comprends il peut y
avoir une facilité à allons vite à
l'essentiel et sait il ya aussi des
séries qui sont plus exigeantes que
d'autres quand on prend là on a parlé
the left over mais quand on prend aussi
de man in the right castle qui attirait
du bouquin de 2,10 que lui même qui a
été l'auteur de blade runner et qui a
donné ce fameux blade runner
cinématographique enfin on peut pas
jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain si je
puis dire qu'il ya des selles d'ailleurs
c'est une série qui est pas si facile
d'accès des cinq sens très longue très
sombre c'est une chronique qui n'est
jamais non plus extrêmement facile donc
je pense que je comprends le propos que
vous défendez bien sûr françois je peux
y souscrit en partie parce que je
comprends bien de quoi nous parlons de
la question capitalistique de la
question de l'économie de l'attention de
la consommation et non plus de la
culture et tout ça je comprends mille
fois évidemment mais néanmoins
je trouve que c'est un peu aller vite en
besogne que ce texte nous d'abord vous
avez vous avez écrit qu il vraiment
jette un petit peu tout en pâture il met
un peu tous au même plan est aussi et
j'en terminerai l'a peut-être aussi
cesser le débat éternel 1 est ce qu'il
ya un filtre entre nous et la télévision
est ce qu'à un filtre en tonneaux et le
cinéma est ce que finalement nous
filtrons ou est-ce que nous prenons
toutes les informations comme ça comme
des oies que l'on gave et on aurait pas
de filtre alors là il ya deux écoles et
ernée alors dans l'économie et dans
l'est la sociologie des médias on le
sait bien l'école de frankfort et les
autres et bien là je serais moi un petit
peu entre les deux je pense qu à la fois
évidemment il peut y avoir du gavage
mais il peut y avoir aussi des moments
de grande ouverture culturelle moi pour
mon bouquin je suis allé mais voilà au
sénégal au nigeria au japon en corée du
sud
je suis allé en chine et c'était aussi
une expérience j'allais dire
géopolitique extraordinaire alors voilà
donc je pense qu'il ne faut pas
peut-être tout égaliser en fait dans
l'analyse 1 et je pense qu'il faut
peut-être un peu nous faire le tri et et
pas jeter le bébé avec l'eau du bain si
je puis dire comme ça néanmoins je vais
je vais être obligé de généraliser parce
que sinon on peut pas qu'on ne peut pas
discuter on attend ça oublier qu'au
xxème siècle les séries
n'étaient pas des feuilletons j'entends
par là que amicalement vôtre ou ou
chapeau melon et bottes de cuir ça nous
racontait une histoire par épisode on
pouvait sauter un épisode
on s'y retrouver quand même puisque ça
nous raconter une nouvelle histoire à
chaque fois il s'est est vrai de toutes
les séries américaines
à l'époque il ya eu effectivement des
feuilletons comme dallas mais c'est
autre chose et puis d'ailleurs c'était
presque plus bas de gamme encore que les
vraies séries qui elle même était quand
même bas de gamme par rapport au cinéma
mais bon il y avait cette idée là ça
change avec les sopranos grosso modo à
la fin du xxème siècle au début du dix
du 21e là tout à coup on fait des
feuilletons c'est à dire que les
sopranos ça va durer 80 6 épisodes
quatre-vingt six épisodes de suite et si
on loupe 1 on a vraiment loupé quelque
chose game of thrones c'est 30 heures
d'attention 30 heures de suite et pour
quelqu'un qui aujourd'hui regarde game
of thrones d'un bloc ces 30 heures mad
men c'est 57 eur et enfin lost c'est 90
heures ça change quand même certaines
choses
alors effectivement d'autant plus si les
scènes sont courtes mais oublions lido à
l'idée que les aides sont courtes et
pensons que l'histoire est très très
longue et ce qui explique aussi la
multitude de personnages la multitude de
personnages elle n'est pas là seulement
pour qu'on se reconnaissent tous
dans les personnages de séries mais elle
est aussi parce qu'il faut bien meubler
90 heures
déjà sur cette durée de consommation
d'une série lambda par exemple 50 heures
60 heures sont 10 heures bon comment
dire c'est du temps c'est du temps qu'on
passe et c'est du temps qu'on pense pas
autre chose non comment dire moi je me
suis pas spécialisé dans la critique des
séries j'ai écrit froid quatre textes
bon voilà c'est pas ce n'est pas une
obsession chez moi c'est pas le coeur de
ma de mon deux mondes édifice qu'on
sexuelle bon pas du tout mais je me suis
étonné du fait que contrairement à ce
qui s'était passé pour l'avènement du
cinéma au début 20e pour l'avènement de
la télévision après guerre en gros où
tout de suite il ya eu comme ça une
volée de bois verts critiquent notamment
venant estimant des instances de
légitimation qui ont tout de suite
dénigrer la télévision disant qu'elle
allait décérébrés le monde entier le
cinéma pareils a fait l'objet
immédiatement mais vraiment d'énormément
de texte pour dire que c'était un art
cas les hypnotiser les masses et que bon
voilà et que ce serait le vecteur de
toutes les manipulations planétaire
cette chose là alors très très vite
encore une fois la série a été légitimée
j'étais aux cahiers du cinéma au début
des années 2000 et on a été parmi les
premiers dans la sphère intellectuelle à
dire les soprano il se passe quelque
chose de majeur aux six feet under il se
passe quelque chose de majeur et puis
the wire peu de temps après mais je lui
avant il y avait eu l'homme de fer le
fugitif et que vous trouvez ça pas
terrible à 30 ou 40 ans d'un ce qu'on
considérait que ces objets étaient
beaucoup plus intéressant et je pense
qu'il l'était il était il se passait
quelque chose donc très très vite sa
légitimation très très vite il ya eu une
profusion de travaux universitaires et
intellectuels dessus et est très très
vite c'est devenu une forme hégémonique
vraiment une forme hégémonique c'est la
forme culturelle en tout cas la forme
audiovisuelle dominante depuis 15-20 ans
il est tout à fait étonnant que ce soit
pas accompagnée d'un geste critique
allah allah écoles de france francfort
comme disait virginie je veux dire à la
adorno ça c'est tout à fait étonnant et
là ça me laisse un peu perplexe et à ce
titre là quand je me suis permis de
commettre quelques textes pour dire hey
les gars on se calme un peu il ya quand
même parce que parce que si ce n'était
pas une forme hégémonique si c'était une
forme parmi d'autres et si par ailleurs
je n'avais pas l'impression que cette
forme était en train de vampiriser tout
un tas d'autres formes par exemple au
cinéma il faudrait voir comment mais
surtout en termes odeurs c'est dire que
les cinq notoire que vous passez devant
mad men ou un peu plus ou un peu moins
voulait pas c'est plutôt un film vous
dépassez pas à lire donc je ne suis pas
en train de promouvoir la lecture contre
les séries les gens sont bien ce qu'ils
veulent je n'ai pas l'âme d'un censeur
ni de capter qui donnerait des leçons
comme ça disons de pratiques culturelles
aux uns et aux autres et je fais
effectivement comme virginie crédit aux
spectateurs de série de cuisiner quelque
chose d'intéressant dans sa tête je n'ai
aucun problème là dessus mais c'est une
forme hégémonique et à ce titre là elle
prend des parts sur les autres et donc
donc c'est pas forcément c'est pas la
fête quoi c'est pas on vit pas dans un
monde comme ça où tout serait à peu près
cool raillard la série ça serait génial
ça se seraient ajoutées à d'autres
choses ça c'est pas ajoutées à d'autres
choses sa prise à absorber dans mais
moins de choses et d'abord des heures et
d'aborder alors maintenant le bilingue
pour moi moi je parle presque en un
autre pôle og
fraternelle vis-à-vis de mes semblables
c'est les heures que tu passes devant
une série toi mon frère humain est ce
que c'est des heures ou en toi il se
passe des choses qui sont d'une
intensité qui mérite que tu y passent
autant de temps c'est ça ma question moi
je constate sur moi que les séries à un
moment où je laissais passer je les
laisse passer devant - et qu'elles
finissent par maints différé qu'elle
mène dans une sorte de semer attention
de relative hypnose il fait que ça
m'avait frappé je terminerais là dessus
ça allait frapper j'avais entendu mills
à l'aide d'amis j'entende deux copains à
moi un copain ou une copine qui était
david est brillantissime en général
quand il parlait de films voilà ce
cinéma là il parlait de hauts blancs
dont c'est plutôt la fin des années 2000
et là je les trouvais d'un seul coup
extrêmement nul dans la critique celle
qui disait pas un truc intéressant et je
m'étais dit mais en fait est ce que
cette forme là ne finit pas par désarmer
tout geste critique parce que je
voudrais aussi dire je suis un peu trop
long pardon mais que vous disiez qu'on
peut on peut pas rater des épisodes de
mad men ou parce que ces feuilletons non
on ne peut pas les rater c'est sûr ça
c'est possible moi je crois que la série
allait aussi construite pour qu'on
oublie les épisodes à mesure parce que
sinon on ne pourrait pas encaisser temps
d'invraisemblances parce qu'il arrive
que des rebondissements de la saison 3
soit tout à fait en contradiction avec
ce qu'étaient les postulats narratif et
thématique de la saison 1 donc c'est une
machine où on finit par oublier tout ce
qu'on a vu précédemment et surtout il
faut oublier ce qu'on a vu précédemment
sinon on ne manquait serait pas autant
d'invraisemblances donc je pense que en
dernière instance on peut pas avoir un
geste critique véritable sur sur huit
saisons de série dans la mesure où on ne
peut pas se représenter dans son
entièreté une série puisque tout est
fait pour qu'on n'oublie à mesure pierre
cornillon on a trois minutes avant la
pause
alors d'abord je pense qu'il faudrait
revenir sur 7 sur cette histoire en fait
des séries qui ont rôdé parce que
n'oublions pas quand même que lassé des
séries télévisées sont massivement
regarder à sont peut-être une vue
magnifique aujourd'hui mais elles sont
quand même massivement regarder encore
une fois depuis des années 50 que les
séries qui sont justement considéré
comme non légitimes des seuils des
années 50 aux années 2000 sont
excessivement intéressante et novatrice
en termes de forme et c'est qu'il faut
complètement revoir en fait tout ce
schéma d'appréhension de la cei par
ailleurs la ce qui entre en train d'être
dit on ne peut pas appréhender alors si
on peut appréhender justement experts
mon avis l'intérêt de la série c'est sa
longueur et on peut appréhender 15
saisons on peut les revoir on peut avoir
un geste critiques sur cc sur sept ce
temps là c'est parce que c'est quelque
chose de spécifique mais ce n'est pas
quelque chose qui est fait pour être
oublié au contraire les grandes séries
sont faites pour être revu comme les
grands films comme les grands livres et
en au contraire il y a ce n'est pas
qu'une question justement de cohérent
narrative là vous revenez justement sur
sur votre propre critique une ce n'est
pas simplement une question de la
relation c'est une question de
construction d'une configuration et
d'une structure qui va avoir une
multitude de sens qui va avoir une
multitude de niveaux d'expérience pour
les spectateurs et ça ce n'est possible
qu'avec une telle parce que justement on
peut suivre une série pendant dix ans
pendant 15 ans et ça ne s'inscrit dans
nos vies dont sage je pense que c'est la
richesse des séries et au contraire ça
n'amène pas du tout vers l'oubli mais au
contraire dans la mémoire je pense si
très juste l'ofce juste lost qui vous y
avait des flashbacks mais où on a
inventé le flash foward c'est à dire que
tout à coup on voyait en même temps
qu'on suivait les péripéties des
personnages envoyaient leurs futures
toutacoo s'intercaler dans le présent ce
qu'on n'avait jamais vu par exemple dans
le cinéma mais est ce que c'est une
invention formelle ou est ce que c'est
un truc ça faudrait voir ça il faudrait
aussi évaluer les formes esthétiques
quoi moi je demande à voir quand même on
avait approché la même chose dans le
jour se lève quand on a vu le premier
flash back on m'a dit c'est un truc mais
moi je compte peut-être que les
flashbacks sont des trucs je les ai donc
il faudrait il faudra aussi s'entendre
sur ce que c'est qu'une fois moi je suis
quand même un peu je veux bien croire
effectivement la série a été
intéressante en deux mots la série a été
intéressante dès les années 50 j'ai pas
forcément c'est de la culture pour pour
en juger mes proches et assez perplexe
sur le fait qu'elle ait été si inventif
formellement donc moi j'aimerais bien
qu'on me donne un peu d exemple d'
inventions formelles majeur dans ces
séries là en général on cite le
prisonnier mais on fait une pause et on
y revient juste après
[Musique]
alors de la coop 26 et d'un g20
particulièrement tourné sur le climat
comment répondre à nos besoins
énergétiques tout en prenant en compte
les défis environnementaux comme
d'habitude si vous voulez les coptes
sont des endroits où on fixe la date de
la prochaine coop les émissions de co2
n'ont jamais autant augmenté au niveau
mondial que depuis qu'on est saine été
abaissées aujourd'hui on a un espèce de
mots d'ordre qui est de fermer les
usines nucléaires mais sans penser à
comment on les remplace si demain on a
tous des voitures électriques on a pas
on n'a plus de voiture qui roule au
pétrole il va falloir qu'il y ait
beaucoup d'électricité produite et c'est
pas avec avec l'éolien pas d'énergie
parfaite on a été le premier importateur
mondial de gaz de schiste par contre
qu'est ce qu'on fait en france 24
[Musique]
lié à ces dérives du classique basé sur
l'ésotérisme et il ya un autre terrain
de jeu pour les gourous qu'on a
découvert notamment avec la crise
sanitaire 1 c'est internet on est moins
ceux des jo de mystique moins religieuse
comme on peut on pouvait l'avoir à
110,80 que sur des phénomènes qui vont
concerner la santé ou l'alimentation et
la crise du coc vide à renforcer cette
nouvelle porte d'entrée dans les dérives
sectaires ou des gourous ont plutôt
parlé de vaccination plutôt parler
d'alimentation plutôt parler de guérison
au lieu d'aller directement sur un
terrain qui sera un terrain religieux ou
mystique on retrouve par exemple dans
les dernières manifestations anti
vaccins contre locaux vides certains
éléments qui se rattachent à des
mouvements à tendance sectaire qui
historiquement sont opposés à toute
vaccination
[Musique]
on reprend ce débat sur des séries avec
françois bégaudeau qui dans le nouveau
monde paru en août dernier aux éditions
amsterdam a écrit l'article sur les
séries virginie martin qui a publié
juste au même moment le charme discret
des séries chez human sciences éclaire
cornillon qui est là est l'auteur de
sérialité transmédia lite est paru chez
honoré champion en 2018 on a parlé du
temps de la longueur des des séries
feuilletonnantes
aujourd'hui j'aimerais que est on est on
faisait allusion au nombre de
personnages évidemment il ya on a
beaucoup de temps donc on a beaucoup de
personnages mais il ya quelque chose
qu'il faut il caractérise les séries
d'aujourd'hui aussi c'est la diversité
de ses personnages il y avait plusieurs
personnages dans les séries d'autrefois
y compris dans les feuilletons il y
avait sous hélène et bobby hier pour
féliciter tous blancs est généralement
hétérosexuels ce qui caractérise les
séries aujourd'hui du fait qu' à la
place et qui a beaucoup de monde on est
plus prisonnier de l'ami du héros comme
on l'a été longtemps au cinéma il ya des
acteurs qui ont fait toute une carrière
en étant l'ami du héros charles denner
au début il était l'ami du héros
dans la vie on a toujours plus d'un ami
et dont les séries on peut avoir plus un
ami ce camp mais c'est sympa et surtout
ils sont tous différents et récemment
dans ma série comique préférée curb your
enthousiasm la dernière saison voit les
rides évident qu'ils essayent de vendre
une série à netflix et il reçut par un
patron qui est un jeune cadre à génère
aux dents longues blanc évidemment est
un mal mais autour de lui il ya un
comité avec asiatique noir
homosexuels gays lesbiennes trans et
même une fille en fauteuil roulant ça
montre bien avec beaucoup d'humour
l'idée que les une plateforme comme
netflix aujourd'hui encourage-t-elle
seulement la diversité mais pour ceux
qui détestent le gauchisme en france il
faut qu'ils arrêtent de regarder netflix
parce que c'est le temple du rock vous
avez cette impression aussi je crois
bien gêné martin c'est en tout cas ce
qui ressortait de votre livre le charme
discret des séries
ya une idéologie des séries est une
idéologie progressiste
absolument on peut même employé le mode
intersectionnelle it et qui est un très
gros mot en ce moment dans beaucoup de
médias donc oui c'est le temple du rock
c'est le temps de l'internationalité ces
dernières le muhr qui est responsable de
l'inclusion justement il la diversité
chez netflix il ya un activiste
afro-américains homo est très à gauche
est plutôt du coddae de bernie sanders
d'ailleurs donc oui maintenant
c'est c'est bien sûr parfois c'est juste
pour que j'ai coché des cases bien
entendu mais parfois et on peut le voir
dans mon sexe et du calcium par exemple
dernièrement il ya quand même quelque
chose là voilà d'une jeunesse qui parle
sexualité et sexe et qui est très bien
représentée justement dans toutes ses
diverses communautés c'est un peu orangé
du new black aussi qui inaugure un peu
l'ouverture de netflix en france et
c'est plutôt pas mal vu il ya des
personnages féminins avec des grands
pouvoirs c'est pas juste la femme deux
loin de là c'est aussi des femmes et des
scénaristes des créatrices qui sont
derrière à la manoeuvre il ya des la
communauté gay qui est extrêmement bien
représentés il ya déjà des séries
fantastiques comme pause ou veneno et
qui sont très fortes aussi sur les
questions de de gens de transsexualité
donc quand ce n'est pas juste pour
cocher j'allais dire toutes les
communautés c'est très intéressant parce
que ça s'inscrit véritablement dans une
création et dont et dans un arc narratif
qui est tout à fait intéressant qui
n'est pas juste pour faire plaisir à
tout le monde mais qui est aussi à la
fois le reflet d'une société la volonté
que tout le monde participe à la fête si
je puis dire et tant mieux on voit en
effet je sais pas s'il ya eu beaucoup de
scènes comme ça auparavant dans sexe et
du cac questionne on voit sans que ça
fasse des drames
et qu'on en fasse trop là des premières
scènes moi à mes yeux j'en avais
rarement vu entre un garçon en fauteuil
roulant et une jeune fille
et qui ont donc une histoire à la fois
d'amour et dans l'amour il ya de la
sexualité et voilà il se trouve que
c'est quand même très intéressant de
donner à voir aussi tout ce qu' a été
beaucoup
historiquement à visibiliser donc en
effet pour ce qu'aime palomo keith
menées entre guillemets c'est vraiment
pas recommandée du tout je voulais dire
quand même aussi je je je veux dire
aussi peut-être une autre chose c'est
que souvent on a l'impression aussi de
confondre les séries et les plateformes
qui nous permettent de les voir et ça je
crois qu'il ya quand même là un débat
aussi de l'économie du capitalisme etc
qui n'est pas tout à fait le même jeu
mais pas sur le même plan la créatrice
shonda rhymes c et netflix même si
évidemment il ya collaboration mais
c'est quand même aussi là un des acteurs
redoutable de la géopolitique mondiale
et des objets culturels aujourd'hui et
aujourd'hui si je puis dire médias mis
ce message en fait à temps c'est-à-dire
que netflix devient lui-même son propre
comme messager son propre médium et c
est assez troublant salle de regarder ça
mérite pour parler du mot qu'ils
menaient de flics sont nés quasiment on
est en plus le fer de lance dans dans la
dans la petite forêt des plateformes qui
s'offre à nous netflix et est très au
fait sur la question intersectionnelle
on va dire pour faire rapide mais ne
naît à ne pas confondre netflix est
élevé et les auteurs des séries vous
avez d'autant plus raison que les
auteurs des séries leurs noms ne
figurent pas sur netflix 1 et que ça a
été dit dans cette émission une fois où
l'on discutait des plateformes aller sur
une plateforme comme netflix et comme
rentrer dans une bibliothèque où il y
aurait des livres dont les noms des
auteurs auraient été effacés il n'y a
pas de réalisateur sur netflix il n'y a
pas de scénariste n'a pas d'auteur il
n'y a pas tout ça car comme millions sur
le sujet de la diversité
oui les séries sont en interaction en
fait tout simplement avec leurs
contemporains donc elles sont à la fois
influencé par les dynamiques qui anime
notre monde mais elle influence aussi et
c'est vrai que pour sûr sur ces points
là dans le bon sens parce que si on
compare justement ce à quoi on avait
accès quand j'étais moins adolescente
par exemple en termes de représentation
et de diversité et cela pour moi que
c'est nous étudions actuelle
effectivement il ya une très grande
différence et c'est ça permet en fait
tout simplement d'avoir d'autres
alternatives de penser les choses
différemment et d'avoir un plus grand
panel de deux représentations la salle
je pense que c'est c'est tout à fait
important mais je souscris aussi tout à
fait à ce que vient de dire justement
virginie parce qu'effectivement on a
tendance à confondre en fait le
phénomène des séries avec avec la
question de netflix et c'est vraiment
très très important de différencier ça
parce que actuellement on est aussi dans
un dans un retour en arrière enfin dans
un dans des évolutions qui vont à
l'encontre de ce que représentait naître
une au départ c'est à dire contre le
binge watching revenir à une diffusion
hebdomadaire sur les nouvelles
plateformes comme disney + etc donc il
ya en fait une remise en cause de cet
imaginaire hégémonique justement de la
série qui a été cristallisée par netflix
mais qui ne correspondaient pas en fait
à l'ensemble des pratiques et aux
pratiques des gens et qui justement là
où on est en train de revenir en arrière
en fait on est en train de réinventer la
télévision classique sur les sur l'état
de forme et ça je pense que ça en dit
long en fait il faut y réfléchir
absolument sur la manière dont toi dont
on parle de ses conseils de ces
structures de diffusion et de leur
influence en fait sur la manière dont
le budget shing ça consiste à s'enfiler
toute une saison ou même toute une série
les huit saisons à la suite parce
qu'elles sont là elles attendent qu'on
les regarde sur les plateformes et vous
faites allusion à d'autres plateformes
comme ocs par exemple ou tout à coup je
parlais de carburant de toodyay la
dernière saison de curb your enthousiasm
il faut attendre une semaine ou deux
pour avoir le prochain épisode donc là
on revient à la télévision classique ce
que ne fait pas netflix je vous laisse
la parole entamée jeudi
oui le bas sur les sur les
représentations fait la diversité qui
est au travail dans un certain nombre de
séries effectivement ça c'est indéniable
il ya deux plans
qu'en dire il ya deux ans de vue sur ce
phénomène il ya un angle de vue je
dirais proprement politique et morale et
de ce point de vue là les séries font
partie de distorsion de représentation
dont je me réjouis dont je me réjouis au
même titre que mes deux interlocutrices
du jour après il y aurait une question
qui est rarement posée et qui se
poserait aussi pour le cinéma là pour le
coup un jeu d'erreurs mais qu'ils
s'opposeraient même pour l'art en
général c'est dans quelle mesure une
distorsion de représentation du jeu on
voyait pas d'handicapés on en voit
maintenant on voyait pas de noir on en
voit on voyait pas de transe on envoie
vous voyez pas bipolaire on en voit
énormément d'accès à la lisibilité des
deux minorités
particulièrement visible en quoi est-ce
que c'est à mettre au crédit est éthique
d'une oeuvre c'est une question pointue
je ne dis pas que je peux y répondre
comme ça rapidement mais déjà la pause
et je trouve est un peu comment dire un
peu non pas inédit mais un peu singulier
je l'entend rarement posée c'est à dire
que c'est comme si le fait que y ai un
comme ça
une diversité des représentations du don
de minorités valait critères esthétiques
mais ça ne vaut pas critères esthétiques
celle que vous pouvez très bien faire un
film ou un handicapé sera au centre du
casting de la distribution mais ça peut
être un très très beau défi monsieur
sous ce qu'on a vu au cinéma et qu'on
peut tout à fait voir dans les séries
donc il faudra voir dans quelle mesure
ça devient disons aux crédits esthétique
de l'oeuvre en question parce que par
ailleurs il est pas il n'est pas sûr non
plus même du point de vue du déplacement
des représentations que ce soit si
radicale que ça parce que c'est une
chose qu'on voit beaucoup dans le cinéma
est aussi dans les séries pour le coup
vraiment je fais je fais je fais comment
dire je fais tir groupé c'est ce que
j'appellerais une logique de
permutations la permutation par exemple
vous avez un film de bras de debes au
braquage c'est un genre qui a été
investi par les hommes bien sûr c'était
les sommes qu'ils braquaient et vous
avez d'un seul coup un film de braquage
ou cd braqueuses est ce que pour autant
c'est à dire d'une certaine manière on a
permuté
donc c'est intéressant du point de vue
de l'évolution des mentalités et des
distorsions bon c'est intéressant comme
geste mais après on voit le film film
est mauvais première chose et la
deuxième chose c'est qu'en fait il
reconduit totalement un imaginaire
virilise qui a toujours été celui des
dd film de braquage donc d'une certaine
manière on a féminisé un imaginaire
viriliste mais l'imaginaire il est en
place si on peut considérer qu'il ya
notamment dans les séries parce qu'on a
le temps tout à coup on voit le monde
d'un point de vue différent que ce soit
celui d'un homme sur un fauteuil roulant
et notamment dans la scène dans laquelle
faisait allusion claire cornillon tout à
l'heure où on voit tout à coup un homme
sur un fauteuil roulant fair amour avec
une jeune fille on est de faire déjà
prévu c'est une ou deux voies seconde
avec les yeux d'un homme noir d'une
femme asiatique du monde ça peut
renouveler cdg ce dont je me réjouis
mais je crois qu'il faut voir aussi la
limite de l'opération je dis bien encore
une fois de limites esthétique et puis
une limite aussi y compris politiques
par virginie martin fait tout à fait
remarquer à juste titre dans son dans
son livre fait comme ça une espèce de
passage en revue de toutes les les ouïes
les distorsions de replantation
intéressant dans les séries elle elle
reconnaît où elle constate elle observe
que quand même le parent pauvre des
invisibles
accédant à la visibilité c'est les
classes sociales jeu à ça c'est très
intéressant quand même alors moi
évidemment ça m'intéresse un peu tout de
suite ça me fait tiquer et ça ne
m'étonne pas ce que vous oubliez de fer
virgin et si je peux me permettre c'est
d'expliquer pourquoi
comment se fait-il que dans le grand
ballet de l'accès à la visibilité des
invisibles y est pas les classes
sociales qu'elles soient en fait sous
représentées dans la dans la profusion
vous seriez là ce populaire des
ouvrières est ce que tu as l'air
absolument ben moi j'ai un début
d'explication ça j'ai un peu réfléchi du
coup je me suis dit comment des finances
n'avait pas frappé mais maintenant ça me
frappe je vais pas la première chose
c'est que peut-être que le coeur de
cible de com comme les séries fonctionne
beaucoup par identification le coeur de
cible la série c'est quand même la
classe moyenne c'est la classe moyenne
mondiale chose qu'on dit assez peu et je
m'étonne alors peut-être que les travaux
de sociologie de la réception des séries
mais je les connais pas moi en tout cas
en sociologie en péril je constate que
les les classes inférieures ne regarde
pas de règle véritablement les séries
dont on est en train de parler c'est
plutôt quelque chose qui s'adresse à la
classe moyenne mondialisé et à la
bourgeoisie mondiale c'est plutôt ça
donc par un effet comme ça des
notifications on met à l'écran
l'équivalent des consommateurs convient
ça ce serait la première chose mais y'a
une chose je crois qui serait plus
engageante ou plutôt des engagements par
rapport à la forme série elle-même c'est
que je crois comme tout est fait pour
qu'une série ce soit confort quoi dire
qu'on dit on c'est la domestication du
cinéma on est chez soi on a envie d'être
un peu bien quoi on se regarde une série
parce que
on n'est pas assez disons en santé pour
regarder un film donc on est dans une
moindre attention donc ça c'est bien
pour la série c les soirs on les regarde
et puis il faut que ce soit un peu
confort donc il faut aussi que l'univers
qui nous est présentée soit un peu
confortable un peu accueillant un peu
inclusif pourrais-je dire en retournant
négativement un mot que auquel par
ailleurs je m'associe est bas les
classes populaires bon comment dire tout
de suite c'est plus moche quoi un cd cd
intérieur plus moche c'est - cosy sait
moins c'est moins qu'aucun ne
commanderait dit dans les années 90 et
je pense que il ya quand même un effet
comme ça de confort et j'en viens quand
même aussi à la limite à mon avis
idéologique de bon de donner deux flics
de ce qu'elle produit comme série mais
aussi d'autres plateformes la limite
idéologique c'est qu'effectivement on va
pas dans les classes sociales et surtout
on va pas là où ça commence à faire mal
parce qu'il faut pas que ça fasse trop
mal quand même on est là pour inclure on
n'est pas là pour diviser or la grande
politique divise quoi je dirais donc
effectivement je pense que globalement
si on devait je vais grossier je m'en
excuse auprès de mes interlocutrices
tout de suite je vais être généralisant
excessivement je pense que s'il y avait
comment dire une analogie idéologique de
la forme série ça serait évidemment le
centrisme jeu globalement c'est une
forme centriste est d'ailleurs à chaque
fois qu'elle met en scène des politiques
virginie aussi le détail très très bien
pour d'abord elle et elle est souvent
faible sur la politique mais à chaque
fois qu'elle promeut disons d des
options politiques ça va être borgen
toute la série est vraiment organisé
dans la recherche de compromis permanent
à la danoise ou à l'allemand d'entre eux
le sandre la gauche et la droite où ça
va être bien sûr les fameux démocrates
américains qui sont en gros les
maquereaux knees la marque huawei
exemplairement donc il faut voir aussi
que ça va pas si loin que ça c'est les
déplacements subversif que son segment
proposera la série alors virginie martin
d'abord oui je bous
d'abord françois merci d'avoir de
m'avoir si bien lu et c'est vrai que je
regrette nettement que les classes
sociales soit à l'ailé les plus modestes
soit souvent en effet sous représentés
comme vous je le rappelle très
clairement peut-être on peut y avoir à
quelques exceptions ici ou là il taille
fire c'est vrai were parle quand même de
ça un petit peu la série m'aide à
laquelle vous faisait allusion tout à
l'heure on est quand même là dedans a
donc mais voilà je pense aussi que c'est
un peu comme aussi démarre d'ailleurs je
le dis dans le livre
voilà le cinéma de ken loach voilà est
aussi rare quelques parents que les
séries qui parle effectivement de leur
très grande pauvreté de la précarité
c'est quelque chose a effectivement un
qui je suis d'accord avec cela le
confort tout d'un coup ça devient
inconfortable
et voilà donc on veut bien être dérangé
mais que ce soit dans une salle de
cinéma ou devant un ordinateur même dans
un livre bon faut pas être dérangé trop
trop fort je n'ai pas vu germinal qui a
eu beaucoup de prix à séries mania mais
bon j'imagine aussi que là il ya une
production qui permet justement de
rendre confortable en propos
éventuellement à un confortable parce
que ça aussi c'est important même quand
souvent ya pu y avoir un propos
inconfortable la production l'esthétique
de la production le rend souvent
confortable ça c'est le premier point
après c'est vrai que je pense que claire
est un peu dans ce cas mais je ne veux
pas parler pour elle c'est vrai que moi
j'ai beaucoup réagi en tant que
politiste que sociologue et tout d'un
coup voire en effet les intersections
nalité le mot qui sonne tout cela se
mettre en route quel bonheur korman quel
bonheur quand même moi qui me suis
toujours sentie mal à l'aise dans un
cinéma très mal guez
et donc avec une vision très masculine
je me sentais à ses invités provisoire
ou juste potiche ou pour rien là tout
d'un coup il ya une implication
maintenant si vous m'avez bien entendu
tout à l'heure françois jeudy aussi
attention moi je n'aime pas ce que
certains appellent les tableurs excel là
on va pas faire le noir le handicap et
le machin etc ça c'est pas très
intéressant il faut les mettre dans un
propos narratif artistique sérielle
global sinon c'est juste pour faire
plaisir à voir aux communautés et aux
parce parcelle de communautés ça c'est
pas intéressant et c'est peut-être
nécessaire mais largement insuffisant
véritablement après autre chose car même
si je puis me permettre aussi
attention c'est vrai aujourd'hui ça
revient véritablement en force cet
épisode justement et il faut pas non
plus dire que toutes les séries sont
aussi dans des 90's heures et qu'on ne
peut pas les voir tout comme ça qu'il
faut absolument voir toutes les saisons
vous avez en thérapie qui s'arrêtent à
chaque fois vous avez l'effondrement qui
s'arrête aussi ce sont quand même des
séries là aussi quand même relativement
importante exigeante qui portent des
sujets importants et puis je trouve
aussi qu'elle ouvre pour certaines des
pans d'histoire alors moi je ne suis pas
critique cinématographique
donc il faut bien le comprendre si c'est
à dire moi je parle de mon point de vue
je vais revenir sur le côté faiblesse
politique qui me paraît vraiment hyper
important et être le coeur du débat
aussi
mais il y a aussi des dépenses
d'histoire c'est à dire si vous comprend
la série x si c'est une ouverture sur la
question du hiv dans les années 80 à
londres voilà l'homophobie
le rouge est
l'incompréhension du monde médical passé
une série absolument essentiel je pense
que si des plus jeunes qui n'ont pas
connu ni le coût ni le palace peuvent
ouvrir finalement une page d'histoire
grâce à une série ça me paraît aussi
être une bonne chose au niveau
pédagogique
c'est une série qui est magnifiquement
fait par l'auteur de year and yorkshire
et donc je me suis désolé et je finis
sur la question politique sur la
question politique il ya deux choses
évidemment mais est-ce que je les ai vus
souvent ailleurs un à part peut-être ici
ou là chez rue fort mais pas souvent
ailleurs mais effectivement il ya un
rejet des populismes et surtout des
populismes de droits atteint même
exclusivement on le voit avec la série
heures à niort justement avec les
questions d'identité et je sais que ça
aboutit à un hacker même si on pourra en
discuter longtemps françois pour le coup
mais c'est quand même important après
sur la réponse il sait pas grosso modo
les conservateurs les réacs les zemmour
alors qu'est ce qu'ils proposent et
c'est là effectivement où on propose une
sorte de ventre mou et je le dis et le
redis dans bouquin effectivement il ya
une faiblesse de propositions du
politique
effectivement à part les questions
d'identité
qu'elle soit à de race de genre de
culture etc il n'y a pas grand
grande possibilité d'une fille chic
d'une projection d'un roman politique à
venir et là moi c'est une grande
critique que je fais mais parce que je
suis politiste mais peut-être qu'un
critique de cinéma ou de séries le
direct complètement autre chose et
passerait à côté de ça parce qu'elle
sort avec l'accord millau leur faiblesse
sera politique ou pas
moi je pense que là la question
politique la plus intéressante dans les
séries n'est pas justement la question
de la représentation il me semble que le
lait les discours les plus forts qu'on
retrouve dans les séries au niveau
politique sont dans des ferries il
travaille la question de l'idéologie mi
à partir d'une réflexion sur leurs
propres médias mais ça c'est évidemment
caractéristiques de n'importe quel art
en fait de réflexion sur son propre
médium or la série est un médium très
contraint et justement par exemple il ya
un certain nombre de séries qui
réfléchissent sur l'articulation entre
justement le feuilletonnant et
l'épisodique il ça ça remonte pas en
fait à un soprano 1 ça remonte aux
années 80 c'est une histoire de la
télévision des années 80 à partir de là
depuis depuis ce moment là la plupart
des séries sont hybrides dans leur forme
entre ces deux éléments là il ya des
séries vraiment passionnante qui
réfléchissent sur la structure de
l'idéologie à travers la question du
statut du personnage non récurrents à
travers la question de comment se
structure un épisode à travers la
question de comment on construit une
continuité et une rupture et ce sont ces
séries là qui à mon avis par un discours
politique le plus fort parce que il nous
amène à réfléchir sur nos propres
structures mentales et sur l'idéologie
en fait qu'il ait qui les habitent je
pense à des seuils comme person of
interest des séries comme dollars à
dollars avec une saillie qui porte
entièrement sur la question du
capitalisme néolibéral et qu'il a
réfléchi sur une question de
d'émancipation des esprits par rapport à
la question de l'émancipation justement
des formes contrat dans son
esthétique ces deux séries qui
fonctionne comme ça on avait déjà j'ai
déjà évoqué de la province d'abyan sur
twin peaks la saison 3 et c est ce que
je le lis faut dire aussi c'est que
attention on ne parle pas que de corpus
justement qui ça
est lié à un certain public - l'effet
que je défends est dans la liste que je
viens d'évoquer on le voit ce ne sont
pas que des felynes justement de
plateforme semi ce ne sont pas que des
souliers de cap ce ne sont pas que des
séries de niche ce sont des séries très
grand public le network et ces séries là
qui sont massivement regarder encore
aujourd'hui elles sont très intéressants
sur la manière dont elles réfléchissent
des structures parce que justement elles
sont actives dans un contexte qui est
très contraint qui est le leur qui est
le contexte de network parce que il ya
justement cet entourage de construction
avec les pauses publicitaires et c est
ce qui me semble intéressant qui sait
qu'il ya un certain nombre d'oeuvres est
en fait assez nombreuses ils vont penser
cette structure là et en ça nous font
penser à vos problèmes majeurs de notre
de notre monde actuel qui est justement
la visibilité de l'idéologie je veux
dire que c'est le principe du
capitalisme néolibéral de me dire que en
gros cette idéologie n'est pas une
idéologie mais le réel et on voit bien
en fait dans ce type de série que on a
une réflexion sur une mise en visibilité
de la structure pour pouvoir nous mêmes
ensuite alors faire quelque chose et ça
je ne crois que c'est une force qui est
vraiment lié au médium de la série
peut-être on peut le faire dans d'autres
évidemment dans d'autres armes et en
tout cas beaucoup de séries qui ont su
tirer parti de cette question là pour
vraiment parler du monde contemporain ça
ne veut pas dire ce sont des séries qui
représente le monde de la politique ou
qui représentent des des éléments
politiques directement mais par contre
qu'il ya moins la vie interroge les
structures du monde contemporain de
manière très forte
si je peux dire qu'une chose il me
semble à votre culture
et sur les séries étaient beaucoup plus
encyclopédique européenne elle est aussi
club éthique est pas la mienne mais il
me semble qu'il ya une chose en avis que
ne peut pas interroger structurellement
quelques séries que ce soit c'est c'est
le parti pris narratif en tant que tel
c'est c'est quand même le choix du
narratif qui est un choix tout à fait
discutable qui est un choix d'ailleurs
café le cinéma aussi c'est que le cinéma
aurait pu et tout un tas d'autres choses
que ce qu'il a été et très très vite
sauf que la forme cinéma godard en parle
très bien alors au départ ça partait sur
du documentaire et puis il ya un moment
où la forme si les masses et
standardiser le cinéma ça allait être
quoi saleh est on raconterait des
histoires qui durait une heure et demie
qui serait jouée par des acteurs bon et
qu'on dirait voir dans une grande salle
tous sens et qu'on irait voir dans une
grande salle pour s'en sort mais dont il
y avait ce parti-pris du narratif que le
cinéma ça serait ce truc qui raconterait
des histoires au point que quand
certains voient dès documentaire qui
raconte rien ils pensent que c'est pas
du cinéma c'est ça existe encore comme
réaction ça et ça s'entend et donc là
quand même le parti pris de dire que
finalement la seule appréhension du
monde possible ce serait via des grilles
narratif via une espèce de découpage
narrative du monde et de la réalité une
chose qui est éminemment discutable et
que la série ne discute jamais et pour
cause puisqu'elle est par essence
narrative je voudrais reparler d'un
moment intéressant du livre martin
elle déplore que le baron noir série que
vous n'aimez pas beaucoup je crois mais
moi non plus évidemment je suis dans mon
rôle vous déplorez qu'en fait on ne
montre dans cette série que finalement
la politique politicienne les coups bas
les intrigues les manipulations les
manigances et que ce soit des gens qui
d'ailleurs soin ne soit requis ou ont
motivé que par lol la stricte
préservation de leur pouvoir ou la
conquête du pouvoir je pourrais avoir la
même déploration mais je pense qu'en
fait cette façon d'écrire le milieu
politique français des années 2000 est
intrinsèque à la forme série elle-même à
partir du moment où la forme série est
hystériquement narrative et il faut
qu'elle soit hystériquement narrative
faut toujours qu'il y ait des
rebondissements des pics des bascules
des choses comme ça chose qui arrive
assez peu dans la vie est bien donc ce
qui va l'intéresser dans le milieu
politique c'est par où ça fait intrigue
c'est par où les gens ont des intrigues
comme on parlait de d'intrigués à la
cour du roi louis xiv et donc c'est de
ça qu'on va parler on va pas parler de
l'ordinaire d'un élu d'un député qui se
démerdent ray pour essayer de baisser le
che pas le mètre carré dans sa ville par
exemple ou dans son périmètre
d'attribution on va voir on n'a jamais
les régularités on n'a jamais le
l'ordinaire dans la série on a toujours
l'exception narrative et donc par
exemple les manipulations et ça c'est
une vision du monde tout à fait biaisé
ces terres que vous ayez comme ça une
forme audiovisuelle hégémonique qui est
complètement évacué la réalité telle
qu'elle se donne à nous à savoir dans sa
régularité
ordinaire non narrative non dramatique
sans rebondissements c'est à dire en
gros la vie régulière que cette forme
hégémonique et complètement est vrai que
ça s'est quand même et c'est tout à fait
enfin c'est une lourde responsabilité
dans les imaginaires ou dans les
perceptions des spectateurs mondiaux qui
se précipitent autour de cette forme
donc je ne sais pas non plus c'est tout
ça n'est pas anodin je veux dire ça ça
mérite un peu d'être questionnée merci
tous les trois d'avoir participé à cette
émission le temps imparti s'est écoulé
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro les séries on en
reparlera forcément parce que c'est pas
près de s'arrêter
[Musique]
à